yeah we got a couple so we just took a
pee break and that uh made me remember
oh yeah this story that happened
actually oh just over the weekend it was
in daytona which i didn't realize when i
first saw the video i thought it was
[ __ ] siberia or something i did not
think it was in america yeah it was like
down the street from where i grew up so
yeah no that makes sense yeah that no
that's what i would have guessed
so basically i'm surprised it's not your
face
so
this band brass against
is uh they're doing a cover of raging
against the machine
and
they're on stage and all of a sudden
this one brings a guy up on stage and
this is what happens
so she signals to a guy in the crowd
like points to him
and is basically like yo get up on stage
everyone starts cheering
he's got a beer can i think like stuck
to his head through like suction
basically
like you ever seen someone do that oh
you take like an empty beer can like
stick it to their forehead
so he jumps up on stage
immediately she's like yo lay down he
assumes the position like pretty
freely
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa i've never seen
the video i know of what happens but
this is wild
she's just pulling her pants all the way
down whoa whoa whoa
ah right
yo the way girls piss is crazy dog
son it's absurd right
i think just spat it out yeah so some
guy in his mouth he like spits it out
she's still singing which is impressive
so everyone else is just kind of going
crazy he seems like he enjoyed it
guy gets up like
he's throwing throws into the crowd
she's telling her to get the [ __ ] off
the stage
[Music]
and then uh yeah they resume the rest of
the concert so
they took to their twitter the next day
and said uh we had a great time last
night uh welcome at the welcome to
rockville sophia got carried away that's
not something the rest of us expected
you know what her last name is what
urista
yeah it's great like a barista yeah but
for urine yeah so she does this she gave
him a shot she gave her a double they
said this is not what we were expecting
and it's not something you'll see again
at our shows thanks for bringing it last
night no listen if you're not if
somebody does some [ __ ] like that and
you're not expecting anything you keep
playing music you're the p girl now doc
that's your thing you got to pee every
single time you could tell some people
knew it was coming because the trumpet
dude like moved all this [ __ ] back oh
really if you watch it like she brings
the guy up on stage and all of a sudden
he starts moving stuff back the guitar
guy's still jumping around ain't no way
i'm jumping around if there's piss
nearby
and i didn't know yeah
can you imagine you go on stage at the
end of your show and then one of the
people just takes a piss i mean can you
imagine like learning how to play a
brass instrument your whole life and
then getting a band with this girl
you know i mean like if you pl these are
all brass brass against is the name yeah
i'm assuming they do covers of rage
against machines brass against the
machine is what i was thinking they are
good but you don't have cover but it's
like think about like
you're playing the trombone you're
playing the trumpet like these are all
like kind of like you were first chair
you were first chairs like your county's
like [ __ ] band group like you thought
that you were gonna be playing at
lincoln center yeah you're like oh i'll
join the philharmonic one yes wow no you
won't no you were going to be background
music for when this girl takes a piss on
a fat guy's forehead
this is unbelievable man the trombone
guy doesn't even seem to be looking at
them yeah he is he's pointing he's like
but he seems like he's pointing not at
her it seems like he's pointing somebody
security like can you get a
bathroom for this girl please
anything the craziest thing is she keeps
singing
i think i heard a shot yeah it's just
extremely metal for a cover also yeah
like it's not your song i'm gone i'll go
she's good if that was her stick and
then she would pee on people oh this is
the best pr dude this works for [ __ ]
ozzy osbourne biting heads off
yeah it's 100 it's a great pr this band
is something now
yeah yeah but they still are just doing
covers i mean who is this guy dude she's
getting custom
getting pissed on by a cover band do you
think he knew that's like letting this
feature act [ __ ] on your face like
that's crazy
there's a can on his forehead for a
reason and her name is something urista
yeah so this has to be something they've
done before yeah yeah yeah he must know
the deal right like there's no way you
get peed on you're just like stay there
i think he was asking for it i think he
brought the can as like hey pee in this
yeah i'm the p guy and then she's a girl
so they just can't
they just can't aim at all like that was
the first time i think i've seen a girl
piss in profile like usually i'll see it
you know like
yeah yeah i've never seen profile and
you don't realize how much it splatters
like that yeah it's insane it's not like
it's like a water park where they have
the water just opened up it's all comes
at once it's crazy really unbelievable
yeah i it's just so inefficient it's
like a touchless car wash it just yeah
everywhere yeah just dumps yeah yeah
just dump why do you think it's
inefficient i feel like it's more
efficient
i mean guys it takes so long you pee for
an hour yeah because it's targeted yeah
it's just a little strange just going
like this just seems it could be so much
more messy just messy eyes and legs like
you don't want to smell like pee that's
not going to be beneficial for you back
in the day
right you need it's already hard enough
to keep your [ __ ] like have no bugs in
it
you don't want to have [ __ ] piss all
over your legs and thighs but you got to
run if you're living back in the day and
like people are trying to get you
especially if you're a woman you're
vulnerable yeah and you're exposed oh
you can't be peeing for too long you
only got six seconds good point you've
got six seconds you're on the woods
you're just gonna get [ __ ] taken
that's right just get it all out yeah
just one dump god dude
yeah but if you're running and you got a
dick you could just piss kind of just
aim it as you're running you know what i
mean i can't start a piss while moving i
can do i have to stop just to get it
going but then once it's going you're
good money yeah piss and run they can't
do that yeah they can't though i doubt
that you can piss when you're like in
like flight mode
that was impressive peeing in front of
that many people having your [ __ ] lips
all out like also
out and singing and it's cold too like
on stage like you're all hot and also
you take your pants off doing a squat
that's probably actually a relief the
pants off is probably like oh it's nice
get a little hair a little ventilation
this is
[ __ ] wild and they're gonna they're
yo they're about to sell tickets like
tim dillon yeah
is it a is it a a cover band is i mean
is that legal
what what is it seeing other people's
music rubber band yeah yeah like you can
like sell tickets
are you just not questioning the
legality of something we've all seen a
thousand times in person i've never paid
money for it i thought it's like
a novelty
you know what i mean like they just like
to do it you do it for yourself but like
selling tickets and you just play
someone else's music the whole time it
feels like if they're still live i'm
always like that's a little weird but
you're getting married next month where
they're gonna play like some popular
songs right yeah you have a band or a dj
come on chill yeah
yeah you get the dj only you got the
band yeah no i guess i guess it is
yeah i guess it does happen that's right
it does happen i i don't know for some
reason there's something weird about
like playing just one band's
songs it's a little because that band
already exists well if they're dead
though if they do like if they got his
prince he's like yeah i'm a prince guy
i'm a prince cover guy and there's a
rule with that i think once you've been
dead for like five years your music
catalog becomes like open source
but
also we need to do prince holograms i
don't know that's true there's or no 50
years i don't know maybe it's like like
beethoven for example you could just use
beethoven now there's a light yeah but
anyone could play beethoven at any time
no you can use it a commercial you can
use it like there's a life there's a
life expectancy to
oh no that's right we were having this
conversation because i think like
disney's about to run out of their thing
they take their thing down all the time
yeah disney litigates against it 70
years after the author's death 95 years
after publication but it used to be less
before disney got in it was like right
yeah and then it was up to 25 and 50 and
like they just keep on litigating and
kicking it down have you ever heard of
the red hot chili pipers
no yeah i don't think they only do we
don't think this is weird at all
like you can just
make money off of someone else's
a lot of musicians don't write their own
songs though but the people that are
being paid for but the guy yeah but the
guy's making the money off another guy
writing his music in that kind of thing
that's clearly not the argument that i'm
making but in that compensated
he's making the most money he's making
the publishing on that music and every
time that music gets played on the radio
he's making money off of it but these
people are touring and making a living
off of someone else's artwork you don't
even know if you give him permission to
even do that like a dj though too
i actually think it's less weird if it's
live only as long as it's dj if go go if
it's not false advertising it's fun
if it's like yo i do other people's
music and i cover i think you do it with
anything if someone want to take your
material and be like yo i'm going to do
andrew schultz's jokes but i'm just an
impersonator i'm not actually him and
they sell tickets to it
run it seems weird
you think rage against machine wants to
get back together to do a 100 person
venue in daytona and have to pee on some
guy's face yeah yeah do you think
tomorrow wants to pee on someone i don't
know you like you guys it doesn't feel
like there should be like some sort of
thing or permission granted like music
is also weird like that because it's
built on covers and like when you start
you just do someone else's [ __ ] because
yeah your [ __ ] is so whack
you don't even have to do it no but even
that like seeing someone do their own
song it's just like
no there's a woman actually in like uh
like netherlands or something that got
sued by tina turner
because she looks so much like her
and she
was promoting her thing as like tina
turner live or whatever and people
thought it was actually tina turner
that's illegal yeah that's illegal if
you name a company close to another
person's and that confuses like
rights right interesting this is the red
hot chili piper's thing i was bringing
up it's a bagpipe cover of red hat chili
peppers and there's tweets all the time
that are like yo guy i scored some cheap
tickets to red hot chili peppers and
then they go and it's a bagpipe cover oh
that's on you though the name's
different yeah it is it is i mean i
don't think they're actually falsely
selling that i just think it's a funny
like sort of coincidence but
yeah it's sort of that likeness it gets
close i don't know it just feels weird
it feels icky it's like
it feels like you need to have a
conversation with the band and then get
their blessings also most cover bands i
don't think the kind of paperwork that
is around the world
i think the bands are like you're doing
venues i would never do and the people
who are seeing you aren't like oh i saw
the red hot chili pipers i don't need to
see the red chili peppers when they come
no i think you still make your money so
you're like i don't give a [ __ ] because
like when a cover happens within music
that's it there's just not enough money
for them to care that's the reason it's
not a music thing it's just there's not
enough money for them to care because
please believe if one of these cover
bands got poppin yeah but what's going
to be asking if there are cover bands
that popped up but that's usually
one point i just want to make is that
whenever an artist
uses another artist's beat
and rhyme scheme for example they do a
cover of another one of these songs like
a drake song or something like that they
have to if they're selling that pay them
the publishing the only way that they
can put that song out is if they're not
profiting off of that song profiting off
of that song maybe they could play at
their concerts but if they're actually
trying to make significant money off
that song they would have to pay
everybody who's involved in the stealing
of that or like the utilization of that
music
all the publishing they would have to
pay yeah so what the issue with the
cover band [ __ ] is it's not whether it's
wrong or right it's just they don't make
enough money for the band's success not
worth worrying about no if you were
saying there's an example no
i mean yeah i think like grateful dead
has a bunch of like cover bands that
like are famous that like deadheads will
also go to like their festivals too and
like they'll do like these little micro
festivals and [ __ ] i know the grateful
dead is touring with john mayer right
now but that's the actual band though
right yeah yeah no i'm sorry like it's
completely like offshoot that does like
their own covers and like they'll like
do mashups and [ __ ] but also a lot of
cover bands don't only do yeah they'll
do one band so like maddox yeah a blink
182 cover band will do a lot of blink
remember them yes
yeah but then they'll also do like green
day and they'll do like a bunch of other
[ __ ] but like so they'll do like that
generation of that era and music i truly
don't get going to watch a cover man
they were incredible they did all the
colors they they wore neck braces like
they were nerds they had so many people
like their arms fans
no no they were dope yeah you could see
them without this gear like that looking
like revenge of the nerds but the
hottest girls proper sunday i don't know
just fun something different you're
gonna go to club every single night
listen to the same music this is no it's
great and music live that you know is
great it's the best it's awesome and
then if you only have to pay five
dollars
to go see it and it's actually good it's
awesome yeah i get it i just i'm very
confident that if one of these cover
bands was making
tens of millions of dollars you would
find
bare minimum maybe not the band but
the record labels i would start with
here's the legal like legality of it is
that these bands are allowed to perform
any song they want under
uh in a venue because the venue has a uh
they buy like a a package from bmi or
one of these like music things that says
you can play any music in our venue but
they can't sell that music and say yo
this is a cover-up so the so the
publishers are making money off of it
yeah they're selling uh their rights to
any song it's why like in a bar they can
play any music they want yeah a billion
people who are paying money to get in
that bar because if you want to go on
the dj thing like
again i don't know exactly how this
works but i imagine djs either buy the
music themselves or they're streaming it
and then the artist is getting paid
either off the purchase of the music or
the stream yeah
and then they're also getting paid off
of the venue that is licensing out the
ability to play that music right so the
publishers are making sure they get
theirs and the artists are going to get
theirs and at least they get a little
off the cover bands but just to see it
kind of wild that you can go i'm just
going to make a living
playing
other people's music yeah and not pay
them at all yeah yeah it's a little
crazy like at least the dj has to
purchase the song
it's two dollars even if they they might
stream it
or they at least get the stream every
time they play it yeah and at least the
dj is like kind of like feeding the
artists as well right right you could be
a new artist you're breaking them
but not the cover band yeah the cover
band is only satisfying like the biggest
fans of the actual band that can't see
the band yeah exactly
yeah it's kind of weird you don't you
would never go see a cover man
i don't get it you don't like music also
i got like
i don't think you like this type of
music
yeah i don't i don't know
like rap and stuff it doesn't make sense
and rap live isn't usually great yeah
and i don't i'm not [ __ ] partying so
i'm just there like yeah i could be
listening to this [ __ ] at home in the
piece okay yeah that's that's what it's
not the cover band thing it's like yeah
music after nine what is the point yeah
aren't there noises ordinance laws i
can't even hear myself think that's so
much fun if there's music that you
actually know like it's you know what
the words do everyone knows it it's
[ __ ] everybody's singing along yeah
it's karaoke bro come on the thing is it
it's like it's the best of karaoke and
it's actually good but also imagine
there's instruments so like you're
hearing live music
ah but there's also karaoke have you
ever been a live band karaoke oh yeah
the best karaoke there is yeah that's
what people can sing